good morning John uh I don't want to
admit this necessarily but we are both
at least in part
Floridians I want to be clear at Florida
has a lot going for it it's home to two
of my very favorite foods the key lime
pie and the Cuban sandwich
it also has manatees and Cape Canaveral
at Disney World and really great
thunderstorm it's the third largest date
by population in the nation and it has a
huge amount of cultural diversity and
diversity of wildlife and habitat and
beaches and parties and the Miami Heat
who I hear do quite well but Florida is
also weirdly kind of the laughingstock
of the nation did ya back when I was
first on the Internet I'd spend a lot of
time on fark.com because I was a teenage
boy and they have a bunch of categories
on fark.com that they categorize their
outrageous headlines into like like
scary or fail or facepalm one of those
categories is simply Florida because it
seems and is also objectively true that
there are just way more weird news
stories that come out of Florida than
any other state lurid a man tries to
convince women to buy cook and eat
iguanas
taped to his bite Florida man arrested
for directing traffic while urinating
Florida man refuses to get out of hotel
pool demands police tickle him the
Florida man headline has become a cliche
there's a there's a Twitter account
devoted to the adventures of Florida man
it's a good read there seems to be
something really odd about Florida men
or maybe about Florida I've actually
read a bunch of different theories on
this is it that the party culture of
Miami or is it the huge income gap
between the wealthiest and the poorest
Floridian or is it that Florida is such
a weird amalgamation of a bunch of
different cultures they're all
interacting with each other because no
one is really from Florida and all of
these theories are wrong there is
actually a very simple and uninteresting
reason why Florida man is the thing it's
a law called the government in the
Sunshine Act and it's part of Florida's
almost unparalleled history of open
government if you work in the government
of the state of Florida every email you
send is a matter of public record anyone
can read it the public has to be
notified anytime two members of the
government meet together to talk about
something and most important to this
video every piece of police paperwork
available to journalists the moment they
ask for it it's actually a fairly
admirable policy though at is
questionable with regards to the rights
of the person who has been arrested but
not convicted of a crime but you just
reporting on the thing that the arrest
report says before any of that has gone
through any kind of due process which is
one of the reasons why other states have
different rules but you combine that
weird law with the fact that Florida is
the third most populous state and with
the fact that journalism is in kind of
an economically difficult place right
now and you got to see a lot of
sensationalist headlines about Florida
man like if a journalist catches wind
that a man of the Thor costume punches
through a delhi display case and starts
eating handfuls of knishes all he has to
do is call the police department and
they have to send him over ultra
detailed arrest reports with statements
from witnesses and the police in other
places riding a dumb story like that
would probably be more trouble than it
was worth because they'd have to jump
through all the hoops that are necessary
to get the arrest report but in Florida
thanks to is sometimes even troublingly
open government there are no hoops I
have an additional pet theory that we
didn't have a stereotype to stick on
Florida like we did for Californians and
New Yorkers and Texans so we had to come
up with something and because our brains
are super good at pattern recognition we
noticed this thing where there were lots
of weird headlines coming out of Florida
and there it was it's stuck Florida
weird news capital of America and
possibly the world John I'll see you on
Tuesday I just wanted to say thank you
to Francesca Lee who told me about this
weird fluke of history that's the reason
why we think Florida is so weird you can
check her youtube channel out over there
I had a pre record this one cuz it's too
much going on in Minneapolis with
nerdcon so if anything happened in the
last few days and I'm not talking about
it that's why thanks for watching